hello everyone I wanted to do a quick
tutorial on building your own models
with textures to load and this is going
off the learn OpenGL tutorial as if you
follow this tutorial once you get to
model loading and eventually you'll get
to a place where you'll load in its
model that comes with it so the next
question and something's not really
explained here is how do you make your
own models that's what I'm gonna show
you is how to make your own models with
textures and I'm only gonna show you
really the basics of it
alright so I've already gone through
this I've set up most of this code I
kind of have done it in my own way in my
my own program so I've got it within a
level loader
but it's essentially using this code
then he has here for the most part
alright so let's get right to it
you open up blender and this is the
default let's pleat this let's make some
other sort of object let's make a
cylinder and really the only thing you
need to do is put a texture on it over
here to the right go to this little ball
which is material and click new and just
scroll down a little bit to base color
and go a little circle to the right of
it and here you want to find image image
texture and then okay yeah you click new
and then you click the little folder to
open an image so maybe I want some brick
so my little brick thing and there goes
and puts it on it and you only see it on
it because well you gotta press Z and go
to render to see that now this things
might not necessarily line up like you
want actually this looks pretty good by
default so what you need to do is go up
here to UV editing and you'll see where
all your your faces are mapped here so
you can go over here and click any of
the faces let me see here
I need to put it on face like I think
this one here face like I'll select this
top face for example that's face licked
and then it shows it over here and you
can use this little arrow here to select
them all and then you can use move or
just press G and then you can move this
to a different spot and if you go back
over here and press rendered you can see
what its gonna look like and the same
goes for all these other faces so that's
how you can line it up with your texture
and I'm guessing I want to rotate this
cuz the bricks don't line up that looks
a little weird so let's attempt to make
it look nicer I don't know if I'm
actually gonna be able to do this
accurately that's a little bit better I
guess but you get the point and you can
do the same at the bottom face maybe
rotate it a little bit oh you gotta
select these ones over here go to
whatever you want to do to it I'm gonna
do a little rotating and then you go
back to layout and you'll see it in your
little world and you can do that for any
of your objects so you just select them
and repeat now when you want to export
this so that you can load it up in your
code you go to file export and pick
wavefront and bear with me here there
are some a few more steps that are
pretty critical to making it actually
work so you gotta wave front and you
save it wherever you want your project
I'm gonna go to my seeing go up this is
where my project is the whole thing I
was working on just called ancient
Archer
so I have a resources folder and then a
models folder but you know wherever you
want to navigate to to load your stuff
and your code that's where you do it
I've already got a few scholars saved
here I was messing around with a
cylinder already I'm gonna name this one
BRIC underscore cylinder and installed
obj and then just export all right now
comes another pretty important step and
this has to do with the way that this
code is the way he has you set this up
this code up his the texture is in the
same path that your obj file is but
that's not how blender does it by
default blender paths to it based on
your computer so you want to go to that
folder you exported it to as you can see
I'm in the same folder ancient Archer
resource models and then under cylinder
and I've got my these are my old ones so
nor are those that's brick cylinders
over looking at brick cylinder obj brick
cylinder MLT so there's the object file
you're gonna point to in your code to
load and here's the material file you
want to open this preferably with
notepad plus plus or a visual studio
code or something not plain old dope pad
that's for sure and when you open that
up as you can see this is a full path
for my C Drive to that brick texture
it's what you want to do is you want to
take this brick dot jpg file and or
whatever your material file is and put
it in the same folder and then you want
to change this path by just deleting
everything except the very end of it and
the reason is in his code here he has it
saved the path to the obj so he does a
search for slash and then saves saves
the path basically yeah right here
directory path substring so it's just
the way he has the load model so if
you're following this exactly that's
what I'm going off of here so I need to
go to this and that was in in my Dropbox
under good textures in this brick so I'm
just gonna
control-c to copy or you can right-click
and copy and then go back back to that
folder you saved then and paste it in
there and there we go so now copy that
so now when I go to my code when you
load it up however you're doing it in
your code but ultimately you're gonna
you're gonna pass you're gonna tell it
to load that texture at some point or
and in this demo code is telling you to
load this Nanosuit you would just change
that to on your new model or replicate
it or however you want to do it so I'm
just making some functions to handle it
quickly here let me save that so I've
abstracted it out as what's going on
here and that material file should now
be found since it's in the same folder
as this so I'm going to do here is I'm
just gonna call this function and run my
code playing around with this bunch and
I'm sure my setup here is different than
yours I've kind of done in my own way
I'm kind of working on a little game
engine here if you're interested in this
follow me on Twitch occasionally I do
stream and usually when I stream I'm
streaming working on this game engine so
now I'm just gonna go ahead and run my
code and I should get that brick
cylinder there it is he did not load for
some reason and if I go look at my debug
info it looks like it's still trying to
use that full path so I'm guessing I
didn't save my notepad thing yep this is
unsaved so in this it's still on the old
path so let me hit save on this and I'll
go ahead and stop my program and start
it over
and let's see if that resolves the issue
yeah there we go so you can rinse and
repeat that and get materials in your
world I do have a little bit of lighting
on it and a point light on the camera
and some directional light I don't have
all the lighting stuff going on and this
other stuff was just me playing around
so don't mind that I do figure out
animations I will make another video at
that point too at this current time I
that's something else I'm trying to
figure out alright well thanks for
watching my video here on co taking
tutorials please give it a like if it
helped you out